[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage and Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships the phone
number is AAA
825-5225 if you want to talk the call is
free and some say the advice is worth
exactly what you pay for it triple eight
eight two five five two two five George
camel Ramsay personality is my co-host
today and Drew is going to start off
this hour in Chicago hi Drew how are you
I'm good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
so I've been part of the recent big Tech
layoffs
um I recently have been notified of uh a
severance payout that's going to be
happening on the first of next month and
I just want to
be a good Steward of that income while
I'm in my search for my next opportunity
to to you know move forward with my
career that's awesome
so you got you got eject you got evicted
from hell
I did it was like the second favorite
I've been given it's my second lap I've
gone through yeah it was awesome and
they're gonna pay you to leave I love
this how much are they going to pay you
to leave
uh it is 22 300. nice signing bonus for
the next deal
agreed what do you do
for sale so Market development account
executive is
um you know kind of my focus with small
to medium sizes it sounds like you'll
have a job like yesterday basically in
that field
yeah have you started looking already
what's your plan as far as career goes
now
yeah so great question I've been
um I've been approached by a few
different tech companies and you know
there is a little bit of apprehension
there so I want to make sure that I ask
the right questions during those
interviews and to see what the future
lies for those companies to make sure
they have the proper head count and to
really stay long-term with a company
that is truly enjoy working with and
um I have two interviews line uh Friday
and then
One initial interview from a different
company on Wednesday so three total this
week so just been trying to
um organize and Excel documents on where
my
um my status is on each uh company that
I interview with and
just to get a base plan going so I have
a plan to
have something a half an income for you
know the month to come so yeah way to go
where I'm at yeah that's awesome way to
go well played you're playing this right
you didn't freeze like a deer in the
headlights and didn't question your own
sanity instead you went right to work
replacing the gig and and that and when
you get the new gig it turns does turn
the 22 000 into a signing bonus
effectively right
yep good job yeah do you need the money
do you have an emergency fund
I do I recently opened a high yield
savings because I want to keep um some
liquidity during this time but uh the
only debt that I had in my mortgage I'm
currently driving my grandmother's uh
old car rest her soul it's about the
wheels fall off but uh then what do you
mind now very
uh before I was uh let go I made 72 000
my first year what will you make this
year with this new gig probably more
right
more than likely it's still a little bit
of unknown obviously
the marketplace for what you're doing is
probably more like 100 isn't it
yeah for like on target earnings I mean
I'm looking for like a base of at least
like 60 and you sound like you're single
with the words you're using are you
single
uh I am single but I've been uh with my
lady for about two and a half years now
how old are you in my life I am 33. okay
I would buy a car with the money
not necessarily a 22 000 car but it
sounds like you're driving a freaking
hoopty and you're making a hundred grand
and I think you need to move up
okay is that okay I'm not trying to
insult your grandmother or anything but
yeah
no you're driving a two thousand dollar
car aren't you
pretty much and you make 100K and you
got no debt but your mortgage
correct yeah you need a ten thousand
dollar car
okay yeah just no I'm not I'm not
suggesting you go buy a freaking Ferrari
okay but I would move up a little bit
and then I'm talking about paying off
the mortgage past that or if I need to
do some other miscellaneous purchase how
much money have you got in savings
uh right now it's about 15 000. okay
yeah you may want to you want to beef
that up a little bit to have a little
better emergency fund than that so I'm
probably throwing about 12 on that and
about 10 towards the car if I'm you what
do you think yeah and if you look at
your budget if you're doing a monthly
budget look at three to six months my
guess is it needs to lean closer to 20
000 in that emergency fund and then
whatever's left get yourself a good
reasonable used car and then uh you want
that emergency fund until you land this
next gig because we don't know hopefully
you land it this week I wouldn't buy
anything until you land the gig but I
think you're gonna land the gig before
the other one's up and then sell it
effectively become a signing bonus and
you get a raise moving into the next
thing so yeah I meant to ask him which
big tech fired I didn't know if he was
willing to mention I was willing to
trash them does it start with a G oh
well just go by letters in Chicago yeah
yeah so we were just in Indy I guess
Salesforce is in based in Indy yeah yeah
I've been to conferences out there when
I was back in the marketing days okay
all right because we're had a huge tower
that said Salesforce on it yeah was it I
didn't ever ask anybody in Indianapolis
if they actually if that was the main
office but I suppose it is
so he's in Chicago so it's not
Salesforce we know they've laid off a
bunch was that like 12 000 over at
Salesforce I know it was somewhere in
that room
trying to get started well the good news
is these people are highly qualified
highly talented highly sought after oh
and so the the goal is they land
something real quick if you if you're in
that position yeah there's but there's
the layoff shirt out there man it's real
and uh so here's here's some we got just
a second but
here's what Drew did right
okay he didn't take big Tech
uh throwing him in the street as a
personal
identity crisis I'm not good I'm not
worthy I'm a bad person I'm not I'm not
good enough to keep I'm yesterday's
Refuge to throw out to the curb he
instead he went oh this is big Tech
they're stupid and I'm I'm Gonna Roll
with this and I'm gonna land uh with my
skill set in something that pays me as
much or more before my gig here is up
and the signing the uh Severance that
they give me effectively becomes a
signing bonus to the next gig because
all because of his attitude he just
positioned himself went oh okay I need
to go make this I'm a sales guy I need
to go make a sale and the new sale is on
my next gig and I'm going to start
calling on customers and I'm going to
develop a spreadsheet my customer list
and I'm going to work that thing and I'm
gonna figure out which one I want to be
at boy that's up to that because too
many times people get knocked out of the
saddle and they lay in the mud and cry
you know for about four weeks and they
give up their chance and that's human
nature it's okay if you cry I mean it
hurts when you get knocked out of the
saddle pisses you off hurts your
feelings everything else and you just
lay around whine about it and that's
normal I do the same kind of stuff but
the guys like him that kind of land on
their feet and then go do this if it
changes the economics of the situation
by 25 or 30 thousand dollars when having
no debt also it makes the tears go away
a lot faster when you don't have to
worry about your payments to those
lenders the next month you know that's
what that's a good point he put himself
in a great spot they're tears of joy
that's right
yeah wouldn't want to be uh
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is budget
friendly biblically based Health cost
sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see a chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Jordan
and Alyssa are with us hey guys how are
you wonderful how are you better than I
deserve where do you guys live
Minneapolis Minnesota I was just there
got home last night I spoke up there at
a church this weekend on Saturday and
Sunday at River Valley it was a good
place we had a great time so how much
debt have you guys paid off ninety seven
thousand seven hundred and thirty one
dollars we also cash flowed about sixty
thousand dollars during that time
okay how long did this take about five
years all right and your range of income
during that time
starting at 65 000 ending in about 99
000. okay cool what was the 98 000 in
debt it was our house oh look at the
weird people yes you are how old are you
two we are 30 years old you're not
allowed to have a paid for house that
young against the law it's against the
law you're not allowed to do that the
house police are going to come way to go
amazing what's this house worth uh 300
to 350.
I love it
love it all right what was the 60 000
new cash flow during this time well the
house that we bought was a total
fixer-upper house she reluctantly agreed
to getting it but it's what we could
afford so uh the upstairs needed to be
completely remodeled the downstairs was
unfinished Vehicles we've got four
kiddos over here cash flowed them
um our garage actually we ended up
needing to raise the garage so the
vehicles fit in it oh there's that a lot
of things was it a short garage or a
tall vehicle short Garage in the 60s yes
oh my goodness so good for you guys yeah
speaking of weird that's actually where
I first got connected with you
um I was living in California at the
time and Craig Rochelle did a series on
weird that would be weird and you came
on and talked about how to be weird with
your finances and ever since then I
thought you know what I want to be
wealthy someday that's how I want to do
finances fast forward to 2012
um because I was living in California I
came home to Minnesota and I met Alyssa
and we decided you know what we're going
to do this long distance relationship
while I'm living out there
so when I remember exactly where I was
standing one time in California I was
like you know what we should probably
talk about this money thing this debt
thing so I called her and I said
um what do you have for debt do you have
any debt and to be truly honest with you
I had no idea how much debt I had I had
student loans and then I also had credit
cards and where I come from my family
finances are very private so to be super
transparent I send on your business and
I hung up
good answer it's got an answer so I
realized okay well you're gonna have to
earn some more stripes for you ask this
question buddy this is a baseline we can
only go up from here so I felt like you
know the Lord still wanted me to marry
her I was very strong about that so
anyways fast forward to 2013 I was going
to be moving back to Minnesota finished
out School
and Alyssa came out she flew out we
packed up my paid for Mustang GT and I
bought a used set of Total Money
Makeover discs I figured what better
time to be trapped in the car and listen
to some Dave Ramsey on the way home and
get on the same page
so that's what we did and we're on our
way home
and you know it was actually really good
we got to talk about our dreams and
really the why behind the what and
that's when we learned hey someday we
want to be able to save up and buy a
house someday we want to have kids that
sort of thing and so
um yeah and I'll just add to that I
shared it was really important to me to
be able to stay at home when we did have
kids yeah yep so we you know so we got
home I sold but two sports cars that I
had and the motorcycles and the toys and
we said you know what let's pay off once
we figured out how much debt she had
let's pay it off and start from a clear
slate so that was uh 2013 we got married
and then Alyssa's parents were gracious
enough to let us live with them while we
tried to get on our feet tried to save
up for a house one day
and uh during that period we had our
first kid cash flowed all that and then
2015 came when we finally bought our
first house which was a total
Fixer-Upper home
um and I'll never forget it we didn't
have a bunch of money to to fix up the
house and so I was doing a lot of the
remodeling myself and one day Alyssa
came over and handed me this little
shirt that said big brother
I mean we're having another kid on the
way which was somewhat planned but uh it
was just a lot a lot of new stuff his
first response was I better get back to
work better get back to work
yep so um so then we had our other kids
2016 so we had two boys we're like okay
Lord eventually it'd be nice to have a
girl so we decided three and we're done
we're gonna have three kids we're gonna
be sure you are yep so um 2017 comes and
we started to finally be able to pay a
little bit extra on our house maybe 100
bucks here 100 bucks there we're trying
for our third kid we ended up going to
the doctor and finding out we're having
twins
so put everything on pause again so
although it was five years there was a
lot of Life happening yeah that's a lot
of cash flowing there's a lot of stuff
you cash flowed the kids and I went so
what you did cash flow okay I get it we
cash flowed the kids uh so that's you
know
turned our life upside down it's like
okay we really need to finish our
basement now we had basement that took
on water so we had to do drain tile we
had to put an egress window fix the
gradient around the house buy a new
vehicle newer vehicle raise the garage
alert so we could fit in it what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is this is an amazing story yeah I
think the biggest thing is contentment
um we paid our house off in October 2022
and we had the opportunity to be in
Florida to gather just the two of us and
we were sitting on the beach and we were
just reflecting the last several years
and um I was like do you recall anything
we really said no to
and we're like you know we can't really
think of anything and we just we're just
so thankful because we just really felt
like it was always a yes if it was
important but maybe it wasn't this month
maybe it wasn't this season but it was a
yes and it was penciled in and then we
would have our game plan and we would
just always be really thankful and
content in that way that was a big piece
and you know this whole time we we tied
too we never didn't tithe so we tied
through the whole thing and you know
October 22 uh 2022 we finally made our
last payment and we even had our email
was brinkmann22 our mortgage login was
brinkman22 because that was always our
goal from the beginning it was a
Bittersweet month we lost Alyssa's dad
that month which was really sad and um a
lot of good things happening a lot of
bad and um you know and we're also had
the biggest increase that we've ever had
too so we're trajected to make a lot
more now this year the significant
amount in the years to come too so it's
really cool we've got a really good
foundation to kind of build off of well
you guys have been so faithful and
intentional While most people are
sleepwalking and just floating through
life you guys went what if we actually
work together and what you found was
that life doesn't slow down and so most
people are going well I'll just wait
till life's life's crazy right now let's
have the kids then we'll focus on this
get out of debt thing but you guys were
just steady the entire time Wildlife was
happening and I just commend you for
that what an impressive couple very well
done guys yeah great job who was
cheering you on out there parents were
the biggest one yeah yeah friends we had
awesome friends they're like we don't
know really what you're doing but you
got this well now they're wondering if
you're really good at it they don't have
a mortgage payment maybe we should look
into that yeah I think it was until then
then they realized hmm maybe you guys
were serious and now there is something
to that you know so um you know and the
big thing too is having our kids we
wanted to really focus on changing our
family tree financially but also you
know instilling in them contentment and
thankfulness along the way we live an
extravagant life in this country and
just instilling that into them and
um you know in this next season we
definitely want to get a new house at
some point we don't know when or where
and we would like to hit the millionaire
mark inside of 10 years by the time
we're 40. so way to go hey we got the
live and give bundle for you let's bring
the kiddos on up The Total Money
Makeover book for you to give away baby
steps millionaire book to read because
you're almost one now uh and of course a
one-year membership to Financial Peace
University City you can either use it or
you can give it away what are their
names and ages yeah so we've got the
oldest here Jackson he's nine Samuel's
six and we've got the twins Oliver and
Abby and they're four buddy all right 98
000 plus 60 000 cash flowed all in five
years house and everything 30 years old
while having four kids it can be done
ladies and gentlemen making 65 to 99
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three
two one we're done
foreign
way to go you guys this is how it's done
ladies and gentlemen wow
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
State and I want you to have a house but
I don't want a house to have you you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host that was
direct to the booth dudes who picked out
some strange bump music there Jordan
that's a new one I know them The Price
is Right
one dollar Bob it's like a hip game show
I would love to see when the Price Is
Right Dave it's not too late I don't
know stuck on an elevator I don't know
what happened all right up next is
Jacqueline in San Antonio hey Jacqueline
how are you
hi guys I'm well thank you better than
we deserve good how can we help you
didn't even match but I answered anyway
what's up hey you know
I'm on autopilot Jacqueline how can we
help
uh I have a beautiful responsible 19
year old daughter who lives with us
um and is about to make me a grandmother
I know it's funny I said responsible
first right
except for that one time yeah
yeah okay yeah my my quest well
financially responsible hard-working
excellent work ethic and and morally
sound
um
my question is how much should I be
helping her throughout this pregnancy
and throughout the first month
um it was obviously unplanned
um and she's had a hard time with
processing the the whole thing and she
is now unable to work so
I'm I'm just kind of
looking to you um it was sort of a light
came on as I was driving and listening
to you and I thought I respect Dave's
answers so let's run it by him
well I appreciate that
um
sometimes when I'm facing something like
that that is um
a little bit ethically or morally or I
don't even know those those aren't the
right words uh relationally
overwhelming
um it helps me to say
not what is the right answer today but
what do I do today that is the right
answer for 10 years from now
financial responsibility you know we go
by yours for years and years and so what
you've got is creating circumstances
obviously obviously a baby is an awesome
wonderful thing particularly grandbabies
if I don't know how great grandbabies
were going to be I'd have been nicer to
their parents
um so you know all of that part is
wonderful so this is a bad metaphor but
I would almost say what if she had a car
wreck and couldn't work
she she ran a red light it was her fault
and then she got hurt right that's not a
really good metaphor because it's not as
babies are much sweeter than that right
but um but I mean that's kind of how I
think I probably would look at it I'm
just thinking like a grandpa right now
or like a dad
and that's where my brain is stuck this
is not a 39 year old who's done heroin
for 15 years and hates me
this is a 19 year old that messed up
made a mistake that otherwise has led a
led a pretty good life is what you're
describing to me
and throw all of us out in the ditch the
first time we made a mistake
so I got lots of grace and mercy in this
situation if it's me I'm just going to
take care of her like she's 17.
yeah and then but but all with the idea
that we're going to lead towards
a sustainable answer when she's 25.
so what's sustainable for her when she's
25 well obviously financial
responsibility career responsibility
mommy responsibility living on her own
and sustaining and developing a life of
whether she does that as a single mom or
later on gets married to someone right
do you mind if I add one more thing in
okay
um
when they graduate high school we have
them pay us rent immediately and the
thing is their grades stay up in college
when they graduate they get all that
money back so it's basically savings if
they don't we keep it yeah
um he was able to in school pay us rent
500 a month and she also saved six
thousand dollars working full-time in
six months so she has seven thousand
dollars
in her savings account and really my
question was do I even let her touch
that no are you guys are you guys okay
financially you and your husband
we are we're debt-free besides our house
this is not a financial lesson
this is I'm loving my daughter through a
very very tough time
she had a car wreck
you know and then that's right
yeah that's what I would do and and I'm
pretty hardcore on tough love as they
call it uh but this is not tough love
this is not a time for that for me for
me this is a little scared pregnant girl
and I'm gonna put my arms around her I'm
a lover She's mine and we're gonna get
her through this but all not with the
idea that she lives in your basement
until she's 39 but the idea that she's
gonna because you gave her some room
here to heal and to not not heal but to
go through this process well and heal
it's been traumatic I'm sure yes and so
um to go through and get back on her
feet emotionally relationally make
better choices going forward this is not
a pattern that represents her life
um and so let's get back on that track
that that she was on and and then you
got a 25 year old that's a that's an
amazing human being with it's an amazing
mom and and everybody's happy and proud
again I'm not enabling into the distant
future but on the short term here
I just completely take care of her as if
she was in ICU or something what do you
think Georgia yeah I'm with that and I'm
also wondering you said she's unable to
work is that just a short-term thing
what does that look like
it is she um developed a pregnancy
disease around five to six weeks
um in her pregnancy before she could
even process and she became so sick that
she was hospitalized
um the good news is that it does go away
the moment she delivers and she's
managed to know the hospitalization
um helps them to manage her sickness and
so she is medicated and she's managed at
this point and able to function but it's
very unpredictable so she's not able to
get another job yeah okay this is a 19
year old
and a baby
take care just take care of them
yeah that's what I would do
uh yeah exactly what I'm going to do
okay you're a good mom you got a good
heart and you're not you know you you've
raised I know you're tough because you
raised a kid that has work ethic you
raised a kid that's make you're making
her pay rent you raise the kid that did
this and that and this and that and you
know so you're not a pushover enabler
Mom I don't think I didn't hear that
well I think that's where it goes into
the long-term ramifications if this is
still a decade from now and we're still
living like this in the basement that's
where we need to go we need to have an
exit strategy out of this too once she's
healed up and on her feet in my mind
this is the perpendicular opposite of uh
someone who's 31 years old and does this
and is belligerent and says if you don't
help me you'll never see your grandkid
and all that kind of stuff I have a
completely different reaction to that
person than I do this 19 year old kid
and if you're 19 and you don't like me
calling you a kid I got socks older than
you so just calm down that's the deal I
love that just means I love juice all
that means it doesn't mean that I'm
putting you down but I got a little more
rings around the tree so it's a nice way
a little more age going here so uh you
know that that's the thing so you know
what you're looking for in relational
things period but certainly in um
uh uh Financial relational things is
you're looking for patterns not singular
events
and patterns cause you to endorse a
situation or to avoid a situation and
and that keeps you from becoming an
enabler if you're wondering out there
and you're a mom and a dad so if you've
got a 37 year old that lives in your
basement and will not work that's a
pattern
you need to kick said butt into the
street
because you're not a blessing to them
you are accursed to them you are an
enabler you have stolen their dignity
the Dignity of autonomy the Dignity of
standing on your own the Dignity of hard
work the Dignity of killing something
and dragging it home the only thing they
know how to do is play Nintendo and it's
your fault you should be ashamed that's
a different pattern yeah for moms and
dads and we got that out there because
we got a group of males that aren't yet
men that are stuck in their mommy's
basement and mommy's still doing their
dad gum laundry and if you don't like
that that's okay get you a show this is
mine
so that's how this works wow well
nothing will turn you into an adult like
having a baby so the maturity we just
hit the fast forward button right there
I'm just getting a puppy will do it oh
my gosh a baby that'll push it right
there this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host on the debt
free stage Kade and McKenzie are with us
hey guys how are you Taylor we're great
how are you guys doing better than we
deserve welcome where do you all live
Twin Falls Idaho oh cool welcome to
Nashville and how much debt have you
paid off we paid off 227 thousand
dollars uh 199 and 94 cents whoa good
for you and how long did this take nine
months nine months yeah what do you guys
make uh we started at 155 000 ended the
year to 188 000. uh
okay what do y'all do for a living I'm a
physical therapist and a part owner in
my company uh-huh and I'm a program
coordinator at a hospital in community
health ah very cool all right so you did
not make 227 000 during the nine months
so something must have been sold to
accomplish this what was it it was the
house sold your house yes okay so where
are you living we bought another house
okay all right so with the uh raise with
covid all the house prices stuff like
that we sold our house for uh 350 000
paid off 147 000 of that mortgage
bought a hundred and seventy thousand
dollar house remodeled it cash flowed
that so that helped us quite a bit with
uh getting rid of the mortgage part and
then a little bit extra for the debt
okay so you cleared did you clear the
house yeah so your house debt free as
well yep okay I was trying to follow
that math yeah good wow incredible so
you sold a house and that enabled you to
buy a fixer-upper for cash and pay off
all your debt well
um that kind of did I get that right
yeah so the house sale got rid of the
mortgage and bought the house and gave
us 30 000 to pay off
um 78 000 of our Consumer Debt got it
okay and then you cash flowed a bunch of
it okay yep all right way to go you guys
how long you all been married we got
married in August where newlywed oh my
God so the first the first order of
business is all this uh all this you
know hide the P under the shell right we
start moving everything around we're
gonna get all this straightened out so
what what got you guys so motivated
right into marriage yeah I think for us
we really just wanted to start a
marriage where and our relationship just
long-term where finances weren't ever
something we thought about or um you
know something that we struggled over we
really wanted that to just not be an
issue at the table so that was like our
first big why and then
also just given my physical disability
being a paraplegic knowing I we don't
want Insurance to dictate like what I
can have medically
um long term to say you can only get a
new wheelchair every five years like now
we can we can just buy me a wheelchair
whenever we want so whatever we need to
do yeah yeah you're in control
how long have you been in the chair uh
almost 16 years now oh okay what
happened I was in a car accident I was
15. oh wow okay all right very cool and
who's the uh service dog what's his name
uh this is price like a price tag which
is kind of fitting so we brought them
yeah yeah
good lab huh yeah good good boy all
right so what was the Consumer Debt on
this
um so we had a car that was fifty six
hundred dollars and then my business
loan to buy into my partnership at the
physical therapy clinic was almost 73
000 wow yeah and it's paid off does it
make the Business Partnership different
now yeah yeah it's uh it's one of those
things instead of worrying about getting
rid of my debt for that it's how can I
make my employees Thrive how can I help
them Reach this status and
fill this free as it changes your
position as a leader when you have no
Masters yes yeah so what Hooks you up to
the Ramsay way
um well I've I'll let you start
um I've read your book before it was
handed to me by uh my brother and his
wife she ended up becoming a financial
coach through Ramsey and so when we
first started this we're like hey let's
call her and help have her help us get
our finances together the right way
because we didn't know how to do that so
that was the beginning of that that's
pretty cool that that's an interesting
Dynamic for your sister-in-law and your
future sister-in-law to be speaking into
your money that requires a certain
amount of trust to her obviously but a
humility on your part too yeah no she
was great and I think for me I read
Rachel Cruz's book I'm definitely more
of the free spirit and
um that way he's definitely the saver
but um she really just helped us get on
the same page with the budget and really
giving every dollar a place and that
that helped me a ton just thinking about
like the budget is actually me telling
how we're gonna spend our money and so
having Macy by her side to just kind of
like really understand how the Ramsay
plan works and like going through that
process was a game changer so we
appreciate those coaches was she your
biggest cheerleader were there any
others on this journey for you guys oh
yeah there was there was a lot of
cheerleaders um yeah people at work
friends uh family was a big one both our
parents and helping us with the remodel
because we just did all the work
ourselves and
um we tell people what we're doing
they're like really okay
so how old are you two 31 both of us
how's it feel to be completely free
fantastic yeah it feels good I think
anything interesting right when we
started in January
Guardians to my eight-year-old nephew
and kind of parents overnight and it
kind of felt like a roadblock at first
but um I think if anything it just got
us more focused and taught us the value
of like what this can do for us long
term for our family and
um it was tough but it's definitely it's
definitely worth it your quote um live
like no one else now so you can live
like no one else later was we have it on
a big white board with our goals and
it's just really kept us
gazelle intense so yeah you guys are a
power couple without a doubt you're
amazing way to go so proud of you thank
you good work good work good work all
right we got a the live and give bundle
for you the financial piece or The Total
Money Makeover book The Baby Steps
millionaires book both number one best
sellers and of course a one-year
membership to Financial Peace University
if you've done all of those or read all
of them give them to somebody and help
them that's what they're for the live
and give bundle so it's very proud of
you guys your amazing amazing couple
Kade and Mackenzie at Twin Falls Idaho
227 thousand dollars paid off in the
first nine months of marriage at 31
years old that's house and everything
shut up 155 to 188 000 income count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream all
right three two one
[Applause]
dog to bark if price could have barked
during the debt free scream and an
excitement that would have been that
would have been making history
this is on the job I don't think I don't
think he's gonna be he's a true
professional except just taking care of
Miss McKenzie that's the plan right what
an amazing couple wow very good stuff
very cool hey guys the point of these
debt-free screams is to remind all of
you and there's thousands of them now
on YouTube
literally that's why Essence that we we
meet people that have come back from the
edge of suicide they've come back from
cancer they've come back from divorce
prison back from losing a job of
convictions every possible addictions we
come back from every possible thing that
life can throw at humans and in the
midst of coming back from those things
also decide we're going to get our
finances right we're going to get our
life where we don't have the weight
around our neck where we can't breathe
at night
I remember when I was broke George and
couldn't pay my bills you wake up in the
middle of the night it felt like some
300 pound man standing on your chest
it's not how you're supposed to live
it's not how your heart's supposed to
feel
it's not the way you're designed
so pay the price do whatever it takes to
get free
and then come over here hang out at
Ramsey and we'll put you on the debt
free stage and celebrate your Victory
because you're Victorious you're a
Victor well there's so many reasons and
excuses people have out there more than
ever of why they can't and what's
amazing to me is when you realize it may
not all be your fault but it is your
responsibility the day you realize that
is the day you can begin to take control
now good one-liner thank you if Twitter
was real we could put that on I'd read
it but it would just go into the abyss
of negativity yeah it would just be
sucked into the black hole oh well hey
it was good on the air though good job
good hour that puts this hour of the
Ramsay show in the Bucks
[Music]
foreign
here if you love the show and you want a
deeper dive on your money Journey we've
got a Weekly Newsletter that gives you
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
the newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
George Campbell Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five Marley starts off this hour
in Minneapolis hi Marley how are you
hi I'm good thank you good how can we
help
uh I am calling to get some advice on
how we stop doing too many baby steps at
once
um while in the middle of building a
house
okay how many are you doing
um well we are attempting to pay off
debt have a savings fund and then also
have over 20 percent
of equity in our homes which we've
already gotten that one
um now we're realizing we're just we're
starting in the middle of doing the baby
steps and we need to take a step back so
so the house is under construction
correct and you're under contract for it
yep okay yes so we are uh we're building
it ourselves which is how we've gotten
um our Equity with it
okay
so that decision's done
yeah can't really undo it
okay so let's just set that aside and
you've got 20 percent
Equity because of the Sweat Equity or
you've got the actual cash
we've paid
quite a bit
then plus the flood Equity so we will
have well over 20 percent okay what do
you need to finish the house in cash
to finish the house
the what cash do you need to finish this
project that you've started
would need four hundred thousand
so that's what our mortgage will end up
being when we are done that's your
mortgage is not cash your mortgage is
borrowed money I'm talking about how
much money do you need in the bank
to finish this project
thank you
um we
well we're having a lot of cash flow
coming in and out but we're taking draws
both forehand so really that's all being
done with the bank team for the
um expenses as they're coming
so you have a construction loan
correct yeah okay in addition to the
construction loan do you have any cash
needs
um no the house
yeah okay so if you took no cash out of
your budget you can finish the house
with a construction loan and get your
permanent mortgage correct
correct okay that's what I was trying to
get at so then that project now we can
kind of seal the wall on that no no pun
intended and push that to the side
that's taken care of now let's go work
the baby steps
okay so what is your income
120 girls all right and how much debt do
you have
not counting the house
62.
all right what kind of debt is the 62
made up of
50 000 in vehicles and 12 000 in college
what are the vehicles
um we have two of them
um one is the majority of it
um
and that is a Chevy Tahoe and then a
Honda Civic now what are you all on the
Tahoe
40 000. okay
if I woke up in your shoes I'd sell the
Tahoe I'd amputate the Tahoe
okay you call me because you're stressed
out freaked out you got money going out
14 different directions and you can't
breathe
and you're driving a freaking forty
thousand dollar truck while you're
trying to build a house in the middle of
it
yep
I would want my life back more than I
wanted the Tahoe
okay if I were you you're pretty easy on
this is it it's your car isn't it
yes yeah it is ours it's just convincing
my husband to do that has been the
um what's his problem he loves the
stress
rid of it and well you're already in the
hole when you get rid of it you just
admit it
yeah yeah he thinks paying it off and
then having it for until it runs into
the ground is that would have been a
good idea if you did that before you
built a house
that that would have helped yes because
right now you guys have nothing in
savings because you need it all
um yeah well nothing that we could throw
at any of the debt right now other than
we have extra cash flow each month and
so we've been throwing that at our house
so now it's like I thought the
construction almost covering the house
yeah we've just been trying to pay as
much cash as possible and now meanwhile
you're driving a forty thousand dollar
Tahoe
and that too yeah this is bass backwards
kiddo you guys got to clean this debt up
and you gotta you've got the dead gum uh
cash set up to do the construct with the
construction loan to finish the house
just finish the house with the debt
you've already committed to that that's
a whole You've dug you're set for that
that's a done deal and it's not
completely out of control it's just out
of order
and so it's not the end of the world uh
and then I would look up and say if I
can't get these cars and this sixty
thousand dollars paid off in less than a
year I'm dumping this Tahoe and I'm
probably just dumping it it just doesn't
fit in this equation because here's the
thing your husband does not feel the
risk that you all are carrying and you
feel it
it's really bothering you and he's
walking along whistling through the
woods and a bear is getting ready to
kill him
and you know there's bears and for some
reason he's unaware there's a bear
you follow me
yeah yeah so you need to grab him by his
face with your two hands put the kids to
bed turn off the television put the
screens down and look in him in the eyes
and say I am so scared I can't breathe
you're killing me
because that's the truth isn't it
yeah and he he honestly he honestly
listen I know you know how I know this
guy I'm him
I did this exact same crap to my wife in
my 20s
because I don't have a risk meter
I just go do crap and if it's wrong I'll
go do something else
and that's him okay and he's just he's
whistling along in the middle of that
gum Bear Country here and he's
attracting Grizzlies and doesn't even
know what they look like and his wife is
actually smart and she's going this is
scary
and my wife was doing the exact same
thing I about about ran her in the ditch
man I about killed her so I'm telling
you I'm I'm begging him as the old guy
who made the same mistakes he did to
listen to his wife who can find a
virtuous wife her worth is far above
rubies the heart of her husband safely
trusts her and he will have
No Lack of gain
wow
listen to your wife men Timeless wisdom
if she's virtuous listen to her if she's
a princess that's different but if she's
virtuous you need to listen to her she's
probably smarter than you are and in
this case that's true the case of Dave
and the case of Marley's husband yeah no
question this isn't a Dave Ramsey said
we have to sell a Tahoe this is I'm so
scared we have to do something drastic
yeah to get to say because you run
around chasing your tail is not making
me happy making me unhappy stressed
anxiety Dr John deloney could do a
clinic on this wow
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are ever any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free
see why blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
45 off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today tickets are going fast for
our Building Wealth live tour we were
just in Indianapolis it was a complete
sellout thank you to the 3100 of you
that came out there this week I will be
in Austin Texas for a sold out event on
Thursday evening February 23rd with Ken
Coleman Dr John deloney Jade warshaw
April 24th I'll be in Salt Lake City
with Rachel Cruz George Campbell and
Christina Ellis you still get a ticket
to that one and May 2nd me Ken Coleman
Dr John deloney Christina Ellis will be
in Anaheim tickets are 49 they start at
49 and you can get a four pack starting
as low as 175. I will be there at each
of these events live people will be
signing books and answering questions
we'll be doing a panel I'll be yakking
at you and encouraging you and bring
your friends who think all this stuff's
crazy we might convert one of them you
never know we might help them to move
from the Dark Side sometimes it takes
synonym in person it's a different
experience than just the show or a book
it is and if you're doing this stuff
this Ramsay way stuff it's a good it's a
good pep rally for you you know
wealth building's a journey and so it's
you know if it's a 20-year Journey you
need a little pick-me-up every now and
then to remind yourself
ramseysolutions.com events
well if you're planning a move soon that
can be expensive but I got great news
our studio sponsor PODS moving and
storage wants to help one of you move
for free all you need to do is get a
quote from pods.com Ramsay between
February 20th and March 3rd and enter
the win it is really that simple
somebody's gonna get a free move valued
up to five thousand dollars and ten
thousand dollars in Cold Hard Cash
that's fifteen thousand dollars worth of
value that's impressive cost you nothing
so pods makes moving easier the
flexibility you need the control you
want the customer service you deserve
they're a great company that's why we've
allowed them to be Ramsey trusted and uh
sponsor the studio the PODS moving and
storage studio for the Ramsey show love
it at pods.com Ramsay enter for a chance
to win a free move and ten thousand
dollars in cash
pods.com slash Ramsay don't hate don't
miss that that's a lot of money all
right Erica is with us in Jacksonville
Florida hey Erica what's up
hi George thank you so much for taking
my call hi Dave hey hey what's up
um so I had a question and it is pretty
much whether or not I should pay off my
car
um I know how it sounds but
um pretty much I have
um 19k in savings right now and there
are 16k left on my car but right now
with the tickets there's not much left
on your cart let me say it again
oh 16k 16 000 and you have 19 000 in
savings
yes and what do you make and that's not
including in um retirement savings okay
and what do you make
70k okay you're single
yes gotcha okay all right
what's your hesitation why don't you
want to pay the car off
with what and everything what you're
saying you're saying Tech layoffs do you
work for one of the big tech companies
yes and there's been layoffs at this
company recently
yes
what do you think the percentage chances
you're going to be laid off 50 50 70 30
90 10.
um I'm honestly not sure they seem to be
random
that's so comforting what a wonderful
place to work on The Chopping Block what
do you make
70 70 what do you do for a living
um I'm an I.T security analyst
an I.T what analyst security security
analyst okay good Lord why are you only
making 70.
I.T security is huge
have you shopped around looked at jobs
oh I have and that's my plan but of
course until that happens I just didn't
know no no I want your plan to be like
by Friday
why would you hang out at this place
it's unstable unpredictable and random
that's true and you can make a hundred
working someplace else
that's also true I think so
I got security people working here and
they have I.T by their name
could be wrong maybe I'm overpaying them
I don't know
it depends on what you're doing I'm
joking around but I really think you're
in a sweet spot that is a very very hot
field that you're in I don't know what
level of certifications you've got or
how far up in experience you are but I
would be poking around out there and see
what I can find have you heard of Ken
Coleman that is on the Ramsay show here
that has his own show on careers
oh I have okay have you got any of his
stuff yet because I'm going to send it
to you
I do not I just have your stuff honestly
okay that's fair all right we're going
to send you his book from paycheck to
purpose and we're going to send you the
get clear assessment for career
uh oh and I'll gonna throw in another
book called proximity principle which is
one of his big steps on getting a new
job and I want you to go look for a job
why would you stay there
okay I do understand now why would you
stay there is there a good reason I'm
missing
um
I
I don't know there's a strong reason so
I graduated in 2021
um in the fall so in December and so I
worked here for like a year and a half
okay well Erica here's the deal if you
pay off the car today you free up a car
payment and you just start saving up
that emergency fund again and even if
you do get laid off it's probably going
to be Severance with some cash involved
and so you're gonna be okay so I
wouldn't let this whole thing paralyze
you into not paying off your debt
exactly and here's the thing okay here's
what's bothering me as the old guy in
the conversation okay
not doing that a lot today but anyway
the um
I don't want you
because we care about you we love you we
want you to win
I don't want you to have any part of
your life Paralyzed by a company that is
being led poorly
and when they leave their team in a
position of uncertainty feeling that
they randomly could be killed at any
moment
that's what that's where you are they've
left you they've paralyzed your life
your life is on hold while you hold your
breath to see if they're going to shoot
you or not
right
that's true and and I I want more for
you than that that's why I don't think
they deserve you
I think you need to go get something
else for your sake because I don't want
any part of your life on hold because
everything you're just kind of looking
over your shoulder every morning going
when's it coming when's it coming when's
it coming when are they going to get you
know when are they going to take me out
from the back here 100 games stabbed
exactly goodness the big Tech Hunger
Games are underway boys and girls yeah
that's true and you're waiting for a
random email to figure out that you got
laid off I mean there's no Indica lucky
you know and so what you've got is let
me tell you how bad their leadership
sucks okay they've got their entire
Workforce
thinking like her
that is not a recipe for productivity
loyalty creativity it is not a delivery
of products it's not a recipe for
winning
and so if there's a portion you know
leadership if you've got a real problem
just stand up and go look about 10
percent of you may not make it the rest
of you are safe because we're trying to
turn the corner here on a mess and the
10 that aren't going to make it are
going to kind of look like this and so
if you fall in those categories you
should be you should be holding your
breath the rest of you are okay but they
got the whole stink in place Frozen
because they're wusses as corporate
leaders classic Corporate America crap
it's exactly what you're asking is for
corporate leaders to have integrity your
dad's asking a lot Dave well I mean you
can be a corporate leader with Integrity
but then you wouldn't be Corporate
America so yeah oh my God
just walking on eggshells and how are
you focused at work if you're worried
that it might be your last day you're
not all you're doing is looking around
going well you're at the water cooler
going weird or you know George was here
yesterday
uh it's the uh the Rapture big Tech
Rapture I feel but you know what our
plan works in good times and bad times
so if that's you out there the best
position you can put yourself in is
being debt free with a fully funded
emergency fund and be looking for that
next thing yeah check out Ken Coleman's
materials they're all Atkin coleman.com
guys and uh hey you know work for a
place that deserves you
and um you know we got 1100 people here
we communicate with them real clearly
can you imagine I ain't scared I'll be
here tomorrow this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com
Ramsay today and set up a free product
tour that's netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're glad you're here on the
debt-free stage in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions Mark and Ashley are with us
hey guys how are you we're great we're
great glad to be here good to have you
guys where do you live Homer New York
south of Syracuse oh fun welcome to
Nashville and how much have you paid off
000. ah cool how long did this take six
years and four months all right and your
range of income during that time forty
seven thousand two hundred and ten wow
good what do you all do for a living uh
High School science teacher and I'm a
wedding videographer awesome very good
what kind of debt was the one hundred
and twenty four thousand it was our car
solar panels student loans and our house
you were kind of normal and now you're
weird way to go you guys what's this
house worth
about a hundred and forty thousand
phenomenal way to go you guys how's it
feel to be completely free
great yeah awesome very relaxed kind of
surreal yeah yeah you've been working on
it a long time yes you've been digging
on this tell us your story how did you
get connected to this Ramsay way stuff
yeah so um June 2002 6 uh June 2016 we
had two little kids at home he was uh
early in his teaching career I was just
starting my business we really weren't
making a lot of money at the time
um but I thought that we were doing
pretty good with our money um based on
how much we were making
um but then our our church said uh we're
going to have this Financial Peace
University class and I thought oh I
think that maybe we should take this we
were doing a really what I learned later
is that we were doing a really good job
tracking our spending but not so much
planning it ahead of time so um I said
to him I think we should take Financial
Peace and see if we can be doing
anything better and I said no we're good
[Laughter]
because you're a teacher
I love it yeah I thought we were I
thought we were doing well we like like
did you did you lose the argument or did
you go to class
we're here you went to class okay was it
was there more convincing needed how did
you respond to it
um I was just like we had heard a couple
of other couples that we really admired
had taken the class
um so um I we really looked up to that
to them and I said well if we don't if
we don't like what we hear we can just
go back to what we're doing because we
think that what we're doing is pretty
good so we could always do that and we
were just so busy at the time with
diapers and bottles and he was working
extra at school to try to make more
money and it felt like it felt like
another thing yeah and um yeah because
it was right and the key was though The
Logical standpoint we could take the
class and if we don't like what we hear
we can just go back to what we were
doing yeah so um I was like okay that's
logical that makes sense and by I don't
know a lesson I think the debt lesson
was like all right I'm in we're changing
what we're doing
good good so we got you in the middle of
the class completely converted then and
ready to go what's your church name that
did this uh the chapel awesome very cool
thanks to them for leading the class
that's wonderful way to go you guys
thank you okay now you're old Pros
you've been pushing this rock up the
hill for six years
what's the secret to getting out of debt
what's the secret to sticking with it
that long yeah two things
um I think number one is just hating
debt like I said lesson two
um the debt lesson was huge huge for me
because I was like well most people they
take on loans they take on credit cards
not a big deal that's our culture uh
that's normal and so I didn't think
normal was bad and so having that that
light bulb um come on that said okay
this is this is not okay we really
should shed all this this debt
um what was huge was a big turning point
for us
and uh the second thing I think we were
new Christians at the time and we had
never really heard about tithing or um
you know really giving generously so
through the class we learned about that
and by the end of it we were like okay
we really want to commit to this
completely like we cut up the credit
cards we're gonna do everything
um and we wanted to grow our generosity
muscle so week by week we increased our
giving to the church until we got to the
full ten percent and um I think that
once we started doing that we really
started to see really big changes
because I think that God can change your
money situation and he did by giving us
more opportunities to work giving him
more opportunities to work and we took
them my business really started to take
off
um but then he I think tithing also
changes your heart and um you know it
grew in our heart gratitude and
contentment and really being able to
look at the bigger picture on what's
really important and the Legacy that we
want to leave to our kids and
yeah I think that's Chapel uh Chapel
actually gets to preach the next tithing
message
that is so cool and for those that do
have a heart for generosity this plan
just lights you on fire because you're
going wait I'm sending lenders a
thousand dollars every month instead of
things I actually care about like my
community and organizations so you guys
are incredible what made you go we're
not just paying off the Consumer Debt
we're just going to keep going through
the mortgage because that's a Next Level
intensity
yeah
all together and go any debt in our life
we want gone well I think I think when
we first started it was just the
Consumer Debt that we were going after
and then the mortgage like was this like
far off
um like okay that's like way down the
line huge goal um but I would be sitting
there doing dishes um don't have a
dishwasher in our house and I'd be
watching debt-free screams and these two
little kids would be like at my ankles
watching with me and I would hear people
paying off their house and I was like
can you imagine the freedom for that and
I kept thinking like okay that's gonna
be like we're gonna be 40 45 even that
would be crazy and then God was just
kind of like you can do it in six years
and I was like really how
um and then you know he gave us the
opportunities to do that and we said
okay we're doing it completely
um so once that happened we were just
game on cool how much are the six years
did you spend on the Consumer Debt two
two okay and then it took another four
to knock the mortgage out yep yeah yeah
very good very good you guys are above
average you the typical is about seven
years from the time you get your
Consumer Debt paid off you knock the
mortgage out so overall about a 10-year
process and that's what we typically see
but you guys wore that out way to go
thank you I love it very very what do
you tell that couple out there who's
maybe where you guys were we're going
well it's normal it's fine everything's
fine why change what do you say to that
couple to shake them and wake them up
well actually we're we're a financial
peace coordinator so we've taught the
class at our church now a couple times
so um we were always trying to convince
people to take the class and um so I
feel like for us it's just being weird
being okay being weird and um and owning
it and knowing that there's a freedom on
the other side and that you don't have
to just live like everybody else well
you don't have to say much you just show
up and you go here's our story here's
what we did and they go tell me more
yeah I can't really argue with your
story that's your story yeah hard to put
that down it happened that's what
happened so way to go y'all all right
bring the kiddos up uh we've got a copy
of the live and give bundle for you guys
that's the baby steps Millionaire's
number one best-selling book and The
Total Money Makeover baby number one
best-selling book and another one-year
membership to Financial Peace University
so as you're teaching it now that you've
gone through do it uh you can give all
those stuff to somebody and help
somebody get started way to go one of
the kiddos names and ages this is Kenzie
she's 10. and Xander eight all right way
to go guys all the way from New York
City our New York State rather uh
practicing a debt free stream I assume
they have it down by now yeah
all right good Mark and Ashley Kinsey
and Xander from New York I love it 124
000 paid off in six years and four
months making 47 to 110 house and
everything count it down let's hear a
debt free scream you ready three two one
foreign
[Applause]
so what's the point
the point is you've been listening to
the show and not doing the stuff we
teach and today's your day
yeah I'm talking to you
today's your day
that couple right there was talking
directly at you asking you
indirectly why in the world you're still
screwing around and not doing this stuff
today is your day decide
the the the proof is there we've proven
to you for decades that this stuff works
and there it is yet again with Mark and
Ashley
and Kenzie and Xander had their whole
family tree changed because their mom
and dad took in new information and
changed their Direction people listen
for 5 10 15 years and then finally they
go well Dave I finally picked up the
book I finally went to the class and two
years later I became completed debt free
six years later we didn't have a
mortgage payment
it's amazing how that works yeah instead
of listening just do it and see if you
like it and like they said if you don't
like it go back to how you were living
it'll always be there I mean if you get
out of debt and you hate it you can get
back in pretty easy they'll let you get
more data turns out
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
George Campbell Ramsey personality is my
co-host today a lot of you are planning
to move sometime soon well that's fun
I'm excited for you uh but I got to be
real in most places around the country
you're still facing sky high home prices
and interest rates well they're up too
and they're not exactly at the record
lows and that makes home ownership tough
but does not make it impossible
if you want to buy or you want to sell
you got to make sure you're financially
ready and you've got to have a trusted
and experienced real estate agent to
walk you through it not
Uncle Charlie who just got his license
not someone who does Real Estate as a
part-time hobby because they like
looking at houses
you need a pro who does a lot of
transactions to help you with your
transaction a high caliber Ramsey
trusted agent
you can get them through our endorsed
local providers program and since we vet
the agents from around the country
you'll have the best support whether
you're moving from Florida to Alaska or
anywhere in between ramsesolutions.com
agent to find a Ramsey trusted real
estate agent today that's
ramseysolutions.com slash
agent
Shea is with us in Jacksonville Florida
hi Shea welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave hi George thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
uh so my husband and I are currently in
baby step three and we also need to say
for a few other things this year so my
question is should I separate my savings
into different focused funds or should I
lump it together until my life changes
path what what is it we're saving for
eign
yes so
Michigan College he has about a year
left and we're cash flowing that on the
Navy is paying for 60 of it and
um I'm currently pregnant and we are
also saving up for a new car for the
baby
babies don't need cars
saving up a car for the baby you're
saving up a car for you
so uh so congratulations on having a
baby that's awesome
so what what is your existing car
it is a 2011 Ford Taurus and it has 202
000 miles
2000 miles
um and so we're just trying to that's
your only car I keep SUV yes that's our
only car okay all right and what's your
household income
it's about 55 000 a year I stay at home
and like I said my husband is active
duty okay all right and you already have
children
no this is our first well
congratulations that's just awesome how
old are you two thank you we're both 23.
okay and when's the baby due
on September my mom's birthday September
9th fun okay and how much money do you
have in savings currently
about uh ten thousand great and so if we
just saved up we just continued to pile
on money into that emergency fund how
much would you have by the time the baby
comes you didn't do anything but build
up savings
um I would say maybe 15 to 20 000.
should have you that sounds about right
I'd say closer to 20. if you're doing a
good job of managing your budget making
sure every dollar has a name
um so if you did that and you and baby
came home and everybody's okay and
everybody comes home from the hospital
and you had twenty thousand dollars and
no debt payments that'd be a pretty good
place to be to start wouldn't it
yeah it feels great yeah and then we can
look at upgrading the car
a little okay well let's get let's get
you and baby home and safe and make sure
we don't trade car money for baby money
that sounds good and does that include
cash flowing his school
yes it does
um like I said the Navy's paying for 60
so each uh trimester is about a thousand
and he has two left okay so we're only
talking a couple thousand bucks and
we're done with this
yes that's correct is he still in the
Navy or this is post
oh good okay so pay's gonna go up when
he finishes good
very good well tell him thanks for his
service absolutely and uh so what would
I tell you what will we tell you to do
let me summarize again okay Shay
I want you to do nothing except live on
a tight budget finish his degree and get
a big old pile of cash before baby comes
baby comes in everybody's home and
everybody's okay then we look at
upgrading the car a little bit
maximum of seven to ten thousand dollar
car
okay that sounds good which is way
better car than you got now
and definitely yes yeah because you're
driving a 1500 car and if something
comes up it may be a minor repair that
we have to dip into the emergency fund
and then build it back up but get get
you something that that you feel good
about the reliability and it'll hold a
couple of car seats obviously
um and uh and that seven to ten thousand
range after you come home and that's
going to leave you ten to fifteen
thousand in your bank account after
you've done that still zero debt in this
equation
it always helps me to lay out things in
order and that's kind of what we're
helping you to do here we're saying this
comes first then this then this and then
this okay because it's real easy to get
seven things coming at you at once and
you get overwhelmed and you do them in
the wrong order like for instance going
and buying a ten thousand dollar car
right now and then there was a hiccup
with the baby and you needed the cash
for that you would that would have been
a mistake so we're just gonna make sure
everything's okay then and it probably
is 99 right it's gonna be okay but we're
going to just keep things in right order
and that keeps the stress level down in
your house and in your checkbook so good
stuff Mike is with us Mike's in
Chattanooga hey Mike how are you
hey Dave how you doing man better than
we deserve how can we help
uh so to the point
um
I'm trying to figure out what to do with
uh
uh situation that I got myself into was
purchasing a couple homes
uh before I kind of started listening to
your podcast and
and uh Karen what you're saying and and
kind of uh seeing the parallel with
um y'all doing things that are not like
the world and and the way I was doing
things was more in line with the world
and and I'm a Believer so I'm trying to
trying to make some changes here but
income is nine thousand five hundred and
twenty two dollars
take home uh that's including the rent
from the duplex without the rent it's
seven thousand two hundred and seventy
two dollars a month
uh my mortgage is 14.45 the duplex is
17.89 a month
I have seventy two thousand dollars in
debt consisting of a renovation loan
a vehicle and a couple credit cards what
will the duplexes
uh so I just bought it this year it
appraised for 260 like six months ago I
paid 250 for it I owe
I think 245-ish so
um I'm worried if I sell it I would lose
money but uh but you know I'm hoping to
well there's no there's nothing on fire
you don't have to give it away so you
should be able to sell it for market
value if you're patient
right and it's rented so yeah
it is rented it's not costing you
anything to put it on the market and see
if you can get it moved
um continue to collect your rent and
because what it is is you don't have
enough equity in that for it to
represent anything but a potential
problem it's not a blessing right your
your rents over payment are tight
right any little hiccup becomes a cash
drain rather than a blessing and you
don't have enough cash flow to set up to
cover that drain
yeah and I don't even have an emergency
fund yet or anything like that so also
uh the the house that I live in I did a
full gut remodel over the last year I
got out of the military
a year ago and I did all this within the
last year I was doing this nights and on
the weekends I built houses for a living
the house I remodeled
um should sell for around 360 I owe 290.
it came with an additional 1.1 acre lot
that's already parceled out and has its
own tax ID so originally I planned to
sell this house once it was remodeled
and then build a house on the new the
other lot I think I can build a modest
3-2
for my family for under two hundred
thousand dollars which is which is
better than I can you know yeah it might
take care it may take you a while to
execute all these plans but there's
nothing here that sounds nothing's slam
dunk in a hurry it's not an emergency
but let's begin to move these things in
and out of your life to where you end up
with some cleared real estate and some
clear debt and that's going to put you
in a much better condition
hey man thank you for joining us this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
all of our shows with the Ramsay Network
app on your smartphone it's the only
place to listen to the entire back
catalog of episodes download the Ramsay
Network app in your favorite app store
today
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we help people build wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships
this is a special edition of the Ramsey
show this hour is the entree leadership
theme hour entree leadership is our
brand where we work with Business
Leaders business owners and answer
business questions about your business
whatever it is your personnel your team
your uh payroll your money your idea
your product launch whatever it is
George camel Ramsay personality is my
co-host today he was for quite a while
over a couple of years the uh the host
of the entree leadership podcast and he
has gotten so busy with the money stuff
that I fired him and moved him into that
and I took the entree leadership podcast
a week ago everything I know Dave I
mentored you for months to take over
this podcast well I'm just freaking out
at first that's good to know because
that way if it doesn't work we can blame
you that's right I'm happy to take the
blame and you get all the credit I think
that's in your book entree leadership
that you wrote that that's how you
that's how great leaders how do you
delegate great leaders look for a place
to throw the blame no
all right so here's the deal Entre
leadership podcast is on every Monday it
is a call-in show as well it is podcast
only so pick it up where you listen to
good podcasts and in the meantime this
hour we're going to take calls from
those of you that own or operate or want
to know about business small business
theme hour entree leadership theme hour
the phone number here is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five now it is in important for a bunch
of you out there to understand that
small business is basically the American
economy
it amounts to 54 percent of the gross
domestic product
over half
of the economy is small business
and 70 percent of you work for
small businesses or own a small business
most people don't statistically work for
large companies that's the misnomer
everyone thinks oh well the big
companies the huge companies that have
ten thousand twenty thousand employees
they're the big employers they're the
big employers but they're not the
biggest portion of employees Employers
in the nation when you think small
business a lot of people think oh it's a
mom-and-pop shop it's a solopreneur but
small and medium-sized businesses I mean
that can run the gamut to thousands of
people yeah you know we we Define it for
entree leadership as those of you that
have 200 or less team members we've got
about 1100 here but we're still at our
hearts small business at Ramsey it's a
pretty big small business but but
certainly not compared to you know
whatever big Tech or something like that
we're just little guys on that on that
idea so again open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five a
small business theme hour Raleigh North
Carolina Lee is up highly
hey guys how are you better than we
deserve what's up
I am so excited to be on this show I've
been a long time listener uh and just
looking for my chance to be on and ask a
question here so I'll give it a go
um I use uh the every dollar budgeting
app personally uh and it's been a huge
help for financially for me and just
keeping track of everything uh but my
bills as a business owner I'd love to
have a very similar tool but these bills
they change all the time so there are
some things that remain consistent but
materials anything like that I run a
painting business
um so all that stuff kind of fluctuates
each month and I was wondering is there
a tool within the Ramsey stuff that
would be able to help me with those kind
of things no we do not have a small
business accounting package
um and that's what you need as a matter
of fact you need one that does job
costing when you're a subcontractor you
want to cost out each job which is
essentially running a profit and loss
statement on each job so so you go in
and you have a painting job you estimate
the job and you take you contract for
the job for a certain number of dollars
correct
yes okay then you would enter that into
the job cost with a particular job put a
a dress on it or however you label that
particular job and then all of the
materials and labor that are associated
with that job are charged to that job
and then you put the income in from that
job when the customer pays you and now
you can go back and go well I estimated
it at this and I missed it
and I could you know I didn't I didn't
put in enough for materials or I didn't
put in enough for labor or put in too
much I almost over bit it here I ran my
margins up accidentally and each
particular job is operated like a
separate business that's what job
costing means so you need some uh
accounting software that does that
um I would probably check with the Home
Builders Association and see what
they're recommending on it uh we've got
a very sophisticated uh but it's
overkill for you uh accounting software
called netsuite that is absolutely
incredible uh if QuickBooks has a
business version out there you might
look at that you may look for a Cloud
solution but I don't have one off the
top of my head but whatever you're doing
you're looking for something that does
job costing are you seeing anything
George I mean QuickBooks is what came to
mind yeah they may have some of those
features at this point
yeah and there's another one that does
um we used to advertise form and I can't
think who it is uh that's cloud-based
thing I want to call it zero res that's
a carpet company though but it's
something like that uh anyway I can't
remember but it doesn't matter you you
need to go out there and find something
Lee that does that you don't need
something super expensive or complicated
you've just got to do it on purpose and
you budget it by doing job costing
that's the big thing and allocate a
portion of your overhead to each job to
where there's no Central Global expense
sheet all of it is allocated somewhere
to a job and that's what you want to do
so very very good question George it's
really important in personal finance but
also in business to tell your money what
to do before the month begins we
actually did an episode you and I on the
entree leadership podcast about this
about financial peace for business and
the importance of doing a budget we
actually talked to our CFO here to
figure out what does a business need to
think about when it comes to this
because it is different different than
your personal budget you have things
that you wouldn't need to worry about in
your personal finances well it's
different in that the things that are in
it are different but the concept's still
the same we're projecting for this
coming month what our income is going to
be we could call it Revenue in business
we're projecting what our outflow is
going to be call it expenses in business
or on personal and the difference is
called profit in business and so you
don't want to project losing money so
we've either got to cut expenses or
raise revenues or you're going to be out
of business and a business that doesn't
make money eventually is called a hobby
so you need to change these things and
you need to make you be on top of it and
so many people and small business people
in particular are so enthusiastic
they're so excited they're so good at
doing their particular craft they don't
bother to budget before the month starts
and um then they try to out earn their
stupidity I might have known a guy that
did that how happy were you when you
hired your first accountant oh I was so
happy best day of his life don't have to
do that stuff I hate it it's marrying
Sharon hiring accountant I love it yes
yes these are good rules good rules yes
it's an entree leadership theme hour
here on the Ramsey show the phone number
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five if you want to talk business
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
leadership theme hour George Campbell
Ramsey personality and former host of
the entree leadership podcast is my
co-host today as we take your questions
about business triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and uh that's what I would do jump in
now listen a couple of programming notes
Here number one uh we did move George
he's doing a bunch of YouTube things
he's got a couple of projects a book
he's working on and uh so he was just
too stinking busy to do the entree
leadership podcast he got too good for
us so uh I'm doing the entree leadership
podcast now and answering your questions
people are calling in and doing that you
can join us anywhere you listen to
podcasts I just look up entree
leadership podcast this is one of the
top business and Leadership podcasts in
America today and literally I'm
listening to like the top five or
something so jump in there and give us
us a listen and we'll be taking your
calls on that as well the phone number
here triple eight eight two five five
two two five now the other programming
note is on the Ramsay show which is what
you're listening to if you have not
subscribed to this show on YouTube or
podcast do it
what are you waiting on you'll help us
out a bunch if you do that and give us a
five star rating too uh if your mother
said if you ain't anything nice to say
don't say nothing at all
rest of you just move on
and uh you're not doing anybody any good
hating on us so uh it helps us out
really it does and share the show if
you're listening on talk radio or TBN
let people know where you're watching or
listening if you're listening on a
podcast let them know you can click a
link on that and share the link same
thing on YouTube so share review
subscribe very important on this show
the Ramsay show and on any of our shows
here including my uh taking over the
entree leadership podcast you're the OG
Dave there we bring it back I don't know
exactly what that means but I guess I am
yeah okay whatever you said uh Mallory
is in New Haven Connecticut hey Mallory
how are you
hi Dave thanks so much for having me on
the show I'm so excited to be here well
we're glad to have you how can we help
today
well my husband and I are small business
owners my husband's a chiropractor and
we opened up our own private practice a
couple years ago and we're on schedule
to pay off those big doctor student
loans by the end of this year and we
were wondering when in the baby steps
should we consider buying an office
space instead of leaving before I mean
instead of leasing
um before or after we pay off our home
mortgage
I bought mine after
I paid off my home mortgage and I bought
it with cash
okay I would not recommend that you go
into debt you're not in the real estate
business you're in the Chiropractic
business
don't get confused
so this idea that oh real estate's an
investment I need to go into debt and
get that and everybody does that in
small business and it puts you in a
serious pinch you're much better off to
lease until you can buy the ideal
situation is if you can find a property
this is what we did on our first
building at Ramsey our first office
building we well not our first one uh
our third one we leased an 800 square
foot space then we moved to a 3 000
square foot space and then we moved into
a 13 000 square foot space within a 55
000 square foot office building the
third move we got a
a lease with an option to purchase for
five years
during that five years we scraped our
nickels out of the corner of the couch
and paid cash for that building
exercise the option so that's ideal if
you can find a place now in your case uh
you're probably a candidate for a really
good office condo
okay I've owned a few of those in my
life and uh you know something because
I'm guessing you're probably using under
10 000 square feet aren't you
definitely definitely one one to two
yeah I had a seven thousand square foot
office condo across the street from our
old offices that we bought uh and put
people in and I later sold it because we
moved out of that location into these
new buildings that we built but but yeah
you you're a real candidate that's a
that's a good size uh and honestly if
someone owns an office condo that they
don't need anymore they're a candidate
to lease it to you with an option
because they wouldn't mind selling it
probably
so look around for that and and see if
you can find that but it's okay if
you're a renter for a decade on your
business
are you all planning to grow the size of
the business in terms of
the square footage and need
um I think slightly we'd like to once we
finish paying off the student loans we'd
eventually like to add a second doctor
to help with the workload
um so we would need a little more space
than to have their own tables we would
like to grow a little bit but we will
never need you know five to ten thousand
that's just would be too big at any time
yeah so I mean if if you over
purchased a little bit for your growth
you won't have a problem later
for sure yeah that's kind of what I
would aim at then because one of the
things that small businesses and you're
not going to fall to this but a lot of
small businesses run into is they buy
something and then they outgrow it
and then there's they're trapped because
they own it
yes
I like the flexibility of leasing until
you know exactly where you want to go
how much you're going to pay and make
that a goal you know from the profits to
save up that amount and paying cash
which is a controversial thing in the
business world the truth is in most
businesses like 98 of them rent is not a
big line item in your p l
it's my payroll is but rent is not and
so it's just a cost of doing business
and the flexibility and someone else
dealing with the building breaking down
the heat and air going out the roof
leaking all that crap uh is really
really handy while you're trying to be a
chiropractor now I'm a real estate guy I
grew up in the real estate business so
I've always you know had had a an
addiction to the ownership of real
estate but I've never borrowed money
since I went broke years ago to buy real
estate of any kind including the
properties that we're sitting in today
well people think it's a conspiracy
theory Dave that you pay cash for all
these buildings and I know I know you
personally and I know that you say all
the time we move at the speed of cash
even with our own building projects
we're not going to continue until we
have the funds to do it well honestly I
grew up in Antioch Tennessee
and sometimes I wake up in the middle of
the night and think it's a conspiracy
theory that God gave me enough money to
do this it blows my mind because it's a
lot of money my brain is just sometimes
I'm just overwhelmed with gratitude and
overwhelm with I can't believe I'm here
but I am here and we did pay cash and uh
we did it a little bit at a time I mean
we're finishing up the Ramsey Events
Center
um in the next two weeks or so it'll be
completed and uh it's the third building
on this campus and
um and we've got plenty of room to grow
plenty of room to grow here within the
event center and within the office
buildings that we have we can house
about 2 000 people and we have about
Eleven Hundred so we're ahead of the
curve on all that but the idea that I
would have that kind of money if you'd
ask me that in my 20s or even in my 30s
I would have said oh my gosh no way but
it's happened very gradually over a
decade that we put ourselves in this
that God put us in this position to do
this it's blessings so it's really
really pretty cool the this is an entree
leadership theme hour we're talking
small business and here's the thing
people ask us George
do
these Financial Peace principles from
the Bible apply to business
well
you know the borrower is slave to the
lender
except in business is not in Proverbs
it's just the borrower slave to the
lender period and uh co-signing one
lacking in sense cosines for another
except in business it doesn't say that
in Proverbs you know uh Jesus said don't
build a tower without first counting the
calls unless you get halfway up and
you're unable to finish and all who see
you begin to mock you and say this man
began to build and was unable to finish
this idea of having a plan having a
blueprint before you build a tower
having a budget
except in business it's not in there
so there's no caveats to Common Sense or
spiritual principles from scripture
there's no caveats for business it's no
different now you can violate them if
you want it's not a sin you're not going
to hell for it it's just biblically
speaking in common sense speaking dumb
because you know how much I was worried
about paying the rent in these buildings
during covid
cheer boys and girls
think about it
this is an entree leadership theme hour
on the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
leadership theme hour a small business
theme hour here on the Ramsey show if
you want to hear more of this kind of
content for small businesses we love
small business at Ramsey we have been
one for 35 years
and um we we've coached and worked with
small businesses under the entree
leadership brand for decades and we have
the entree leadership podcast that I now
do answering questions just like we're
doing today so if you want to join us on
that it comes out every Monday and uh
anywhere great podcasts are sold be sure
and check it out that would be apple
Spotify
Etc right so Google play all that kind
of stuff we're everywhere you can want
to listen to a podcast oh and it's on
YouTube so be sure and check that out as
well all right Ali is next Ali is uh
with us in Phoenix Arizona hi Ali how
are you
he's even great how are you better than
we deserve how can George and I help
the owner here in Phoenix Arizona and I
have been trying to grow this business
for the last 60 years or so and
obviously then the pandemic happened and
we had our best year ever in 2020 and
then we ended up with an employee
shortage which
um
obviously made it to where I had to
cancel a bunch of clients I wasn't
making as much money and could no longer
afford to pay for ads for employees
um and I'm just having a really tough
time growing right now with the lack of
workers and then just finances you know
trying to support my kids and pay well
has been a challenge I took out a a loan
which was really stupid of me through
stripe in September thinking that that
would assist me in paying for ads for
workers and training and it ended up
biting me in the butt big time and since
then I haven't been able to pay myself
so
I'm here to ask for your Genius
assistant so what are your current
expenses with this business
I'm in fuel all the insurances and
um
supplies and equipment and how many
people are working for you right now
right now I actually only have two
people so three including myself and how
many would be ideal for you to grow and
scale this thing
uh 10 would be awesome because then I
can actually start working on the
business instead of in the business do
you have enough clients to support them
or you have a client issue as well
no I should get clients pretty easily I
was in BNI for a while and I could
easily just go back there and get
clients no problem it's just the workers
and getting them fully trained in order
to send them to these places that
you know the most expensive part of it
and the most difficult okay you're
running two employees or three
two and you're working in the houses as
well and you're not making a profit
correct I'm working my butt off and then
why would we scale this
well the opportunity is definitely there
well then go get some opportunity you
need more houses to clean with the three
of you you got to get something
profitable before you want to double it
I don't want to double this it sounds
like hell
laughs
why isn't it making money right now
uh just because of the lack of workers
and how no no no no no no no no you
don't have enough houses for the three
of you to clean to offset the fact that
all three of you need to make a living
out of it we have tons of houses we're
working like then why are you not making
a profit on three people working it if
you were doing the solo would you be
making a profit so okay so I was making
a profit until I took out that loan from
stripe and said how much do you owe
stripe
stripe it was a fifteen thousand dollar
loan and then they added two thousand on
top of that and I thought that that
would help me to get for advertising
employees
right because indeed change to their
um they changed their like way of
charging it used to be I could do ten
dollars a day and I was like thirty five
dollars an application so I wasn't able
to afford ads to get the workers
you were able to you weren't able to
afford their ads and that's when you
should have walked away from them
instead of financing with them with
stripes okay but seventeen thousand
dollar loan if you just quit paying that
you're still not profitable
they take out 20 per transaction because
they pay you by stripe
right so I Have a scheduling software
called house call Pro and they use
stripe to process the credit card and so
for every transaction that you know my
clients pay via credit card they're
taking 20
to pay back you know soldiers
I know so you have to shut every bit of
that down and go get a different credit
card processing and just process you
haven't even got that many houses how
many houses are you cleaning
um I haven't added it up but we're still
under a hundred but I think it's like
75. three of you are cleaning 75 houses
reoccurring yeah
okay somewhere around there is there an
hourly rate is there an average right
you're charging per home
okay sometimes 55 if it's yeah you have
farmed out your scheduling you have
farmed out your uh payment systems and
you've all and you farmed out a loan and
you bought
incestuously woven them all together the
only way you're going to get back on
your feet is to break every bit of that
and that's going to mean you go get
another way to schedule and another way
to process payments where they're not
taking 20 out and then you pay them when
you can get around to it but you get
your business up and running first they
stand on the sidelines and wait on you
right and you don't have to have indeed
or stripe around a business they're not
that freaking powerful
I'm sure and I don't know that I would
purchase ads I think I would take the
three people that you have and tell them
I'll pay you 500 bucks a piece for your
friends that come to work here
right and
and but what about local local Facebook
groups neighborhood communities hey
Allie let me tell you what I'm here man
I did what you're doing for a while
what I did for a while was I kept
waiting on someone to come along riding
on a white horse to make business easy
no no and you're you're keep you're
looking for some software some
advertising you're looking for indeed
and stripe and uh house scheduling
company whatever it was called all these
people to do this and make all of a
sudden it's going to be easy or if I
just get more people it's going to be
easy it's not going to be easy you're
going to have to get down in the dirt
with this thing you're not afraid of
hard work that's not what I'm saying but
no one's coming to save you
no one's coming the calvary's not coming
you have got to push back and you've got
to fix this yourself and it's not like
oh I have to go buy ads we you know how
many ads Ramsay buys for hiring
zero
we hired 300 people last year we do not
buy ads we post stuff on LinkedIn we
post stuff here or there but we do not
buy employment ads they're generally
useless the type of people that come in
off of them are the bottom of the barrel
occasionally you can get somebody good
and indeed it's not a bad company but
you don't want to be a slave to them
they're taking 20 out like like George
said it's like a garnishment they're
killing you you have painted yourself
into a corner and employees aren't your
problem the problem is that you gave
someone else control of your business in
an effort to make this easy and it's not
going to be easy you're gonna have to
make it hard again you have to do
scheduling by hand on a spreadsheet you
have to go down at your bank and get a
Visa processing system and just you know
get up get a merchant account with your
local bank and you can process your own
stinking cars only 75 transactions a
month it's not like you can't do those
at night after the kids go to bed it's
not that hard and so you can do this and
then when you get ready to scale and you
get strike paid back you may want to
step back in with them but learn your
lesson and that's don't fall good Lord
yeah run this thing at the speed of cash
Payment Processing Company put you in
debt to them
wow
that is just gross I'm sorry Ali I'm
sorry this is a mess you found yourself
in but there's only one way out it's to
box it and you handle it yourself it's
the only way you walk out of this this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
Philippians 3 14 I press on toward the
goal for the prize of the upward call of
God in Christ Jesus
Barack Obama said if you're walking down
the right path and you're willing to
keep walking eventually you'll make
progress
absolutely all right let's recap just a
second George before we go to another
call it's an entree leadership theme
hour and I feel like I need to clean up
some stuff I stepped in there so
ZipRecruiter indeed
stripe LinkedIn
Stripes of Payment Processing Company
the other three are places that you can
advertise or otherwise post jobs for
jobs and they do work okay I I
overstated that I said I don't I would
never use them now you're only going to
get crap there that wasn't over that was
exaggeration they actually do provide in
some cases
the
a good lead for a potential candidate to
come to work for you or a good lead if
you're a candidate for an actual job our
best results for a high-end white collar
job like stuff like two hundred thousand
dollar a year programmers that kind of
thing is LinkedIn
okay that's been our best results but we
again we don't pay for ads we create a
stir on LinkedIn it's a social media
situation and we get leads that way we
also of course have a national radio
show that we can say hey come to work
for Ramsay and people put in
applications here as a result one of the
ads is in your voice as a matter of fact
that's right and well we have to
differentiate ads versus a job posting
so paying to have a job post that is
different than paying to have an
advertisement where it pops up at the
very top in your face exactly exactly
now
so I'm not trashing all of those
companies although I did the reason
I went there the reason I exaggerated
was the emotion what was she feels like
there's no other way to run her business
like before the internet existed with
indeed or zip recruiter that it was
impossible to hire people to clean
houses so what did they do back in the
day
well of course we had classified ads
because there were these things called
newspapers in those days remember those
now they're pamphlets but um you know
they're one tenth as thick as they used
to be and much less credible in most
cases and so um you know but but they're
you know
all of that to say most small businesses
have grown their team
primarily by Word of Mouth
four generations
and so she was just making these
absolute statements that she's trapped
and if she can't get on indeed she
simply can't grow and that's what I was
over reacting to so I was out of line so
indeed don't don't be mad at me I'm not
trashing you and same with zip
recruiters same with other online
services but if you feel like the only
way you can run your business is to buy
something you can't afford then you you
really have to adjust your thinking and
that's what I was attempting to do with
the two before but um I've helped
friends get jobs just from social media
posts where a friend posts I'm looking
for this person I tag them they get in
touch and all of a sudden a job happened
with no advertising needed and so word
of mouth is powerful even in your own
little SEO campaign that way within your
social media posts is a possibility all
of that's there
um and then the possibility of just
growing slower is okay but you don't
want to take a business that's not
profitable and double it and you
certainly don't want to triple it that's
hell on Earth it'll double the profits
that don't exist yeah that that or or
the losses you don't think you know
compounds think you know and now if you
have back boxed yourself into a corner
where you have more bills like she does
and in her case they were utilizing her
payment system to actually dock her pay
before she got her pay if you box
yourself in that situation then you've
got to structurally change something to
get on your feet so that you have a
chance to pay them because she's not
going to stay open and pay them you
could hear it in her voice she's not
going to be there much longer she's
running out of steam so
that's why I was saying not to not to
cheat stripe and not pay them I want her
to pay them but the best way they get
paid is for her to quit paying them for
a while and get some people hired and
build that business back up and then
start throwing money at the 17
000 to never do business with them again
in that regard now you can use them for
payment system or whatever that's fine I
don't care but never ever ever go in
debt to someone that can dock your pay
directly like that never go into debt to
somebody period but never ever ever ever
ever ever they got a gun to your head I
mean they own you that's just awful it
just felt so bad for you she's so
trapped so that's a little bit of
clarification on that so when you're
hiring our best hires at Ramsey we've
got a group of thoroughbreds in the
building and thoroughbreds you know who
they run around with other thoroughbreds
and so I we give them a a bounty for
bringing in their Thoroughbred friends
to join the team
and if they if they're a thoroughbred
they also know what a donkey looks like
and they don't want donkeys working
beside them and so if they got one of
their friends that's a donkey they don't
bring them over here
and so but most thoroughbreds run around
with other thoroughbreds you become who
you hang around with and so that's what
you're looking for is a an internal
referral system or even a client
referral system you could ask somebody
that you clean their house to say hey
who used to clean your house I'm looking
for some more help yeah do you know
anybody that I could hire I mean you can
just Word of Mouth shake the bushes out
there but this idea that somehow the
only way to operate your business is to
be
Tethered to a digital service that you
can't afford
that's very
uh you you know you're boxing yourself
in a corner you're trapping yourself
with your own mentality and that's what
I was trying to break thank you for the
clarification there we go I feel
clarified do you oh yeah okay good I'm
glad you do all right Olin is with us in
Wichita hi Olan how are you
hey Dave and George it's uh honor to be
honored with you guys huge entree
leadership fans and I'm excited to get
hit up the head of the two by four today
well how can we help sir
so I my question is how do I get my
business out of debt after 13 years I
bought my lawn irrigation business at
age 19 for 25 000 all of which I
borrowed
um and the business is growing since
then and and so has my liabilities
um
in 2020 2021 were kind of poor years we
you know we did end up taking the IDL
um but in that time frame too actually
we built a new building and bought some
land for that
and
um
going forward 2022 we had a really good
year we had we had good growth we had
you know 13 net profit at the end of the
year
um but you know it just a lot of it went
to servicing debt and you know we want
to keep growing but I'm kind of you know
in a spot where
I'm like do I do I try to sit here and
take care of that or do we keep growing
which is you know in our current cycle
it's going to take more debt so I'm
curious to see how what you would
recommend
well it's kind of a Dr Phil moment isn't
it how's it working for you
this thing of every time I want to add
that every time I want to grow I add
debt and it's LED you to calling us and
saying hey I don't like being in debt
but I sort of do because yeah I want to
keep growing and I like that and and now
I'm just really confused with myself
that's what I heard
what What's the total of that man I know
go ahead sorry What's the total debt
uh with just around nine hundred
thousand
how much of that's the building how much
are that's the building in the land
[Music]
I need about 500 000 of that okay
so tell me why you need a half a million
dollar building to cut grass
well we don't cut grass but I thought
you said you did lawn work and
irrigation
we do irrigation fertilization
um so we're in the weed now but um I
mean is this a warehouse a story or
equipment what's going on it's uh it's
some it's some office space
um we've got four or five offices in
here what's your gross revenue in
Warehouse last year we were just at 1.4
million which was up about 50 percent
from the year before and that was not
that was not due to you having a
building
increase in sales had nothing to do with
that building
well when you operate out of a small
building in two locations and Community
you can rent a building
it wasn't due to a half million dollars
worth of debt
it might have been due to you getting
into a better facility but it wasn't
necessary for you to go into debt to do
it so here's the thing Ola if you want
to get out of debt the first step stop
borrowing more
that's first step and you're not
committed to that yet
when you get committed to that then you
can start taking the steps to get out of
debt
that puts us out of the Ramsey Show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsaysolutions.com and click get
started
foreign
[Music]